oh yeah it's that time again to talk
about the latest games and new releases
and it's a party so grab some chips
because we're dipping into guacamelee
Super Turbo Championship Edition clock
lovers return to fighting this
award-winning action platformer gets
spiced up with tons of new content dig
into an expanded storyline a new lava
map this three-headed skeleton boss and
tons of new enemies and special powers
that are brought to the table they even
added support for multiple save slots oh
that is some good block hey never asked
you yeah you like pocket boy oh and you
also get exploding chicken egg bombs
start snacking July first still hungry
huh well taste test the fan fave dynasty
warriors gundam reborn take to the skies
and over a hundred and twenty playable
mobile suits from the legendary Gundam
franchise at my reborns rejuvinated
graphics as you battle through new
stages and game modes and relive those
famous Gundam scenes wage war across
land sea air and now space suit up on
the first of July all UV de lovers might
want to sit down for this one the
award-winning side-scrolling RPG child
of light breaks through the clouds and
on to the vita play as the young
princess aurora and embark on an
adventure to bring the light back into
the sky whoa oh whoa sweet shy of oh no
not you Axl dad here you sell out wash
away the storm July first but turn right
back around because it's time to get wet
sailor people need your help the highly
anticipated ship simulator maritime
search and rescue splashes into steam at
full speed save lives as a captain by
deploying rescue boats putting out fires
or pumping water have a sinking ship
fully accessible authentic models an
interactive radio traffic raised the bar
so high that even James Cameron will
have a hard time reaching it systems are
normal you guys hearing the song will
camp down James
an explorer of the seas take to the seas
July first or further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next time
and have an excellent day
you